err can you tell us about the first
screenplay you sold what was happening
in your life at that moment in time and
how many had you written previously Wow
that takes me back I was still at UCLA
as a grad student and I was in work in
my first year working on my PhD I mean I
always knew I wanted to teach at the
college level sometimes so I wanted to
get those required degrees in early and
I just loved college and I wouldn't let
anybody tear me out of there so I was
still working on the PhD but there was
another student there doctoral student
there whose stepfather was a director
and he asked do you have anything do you
have any stories and I was working on
something I was a head of Novell I was
working on at the time it was kind of
for the time kind of an uppity romantic
comedy so I gave it to David emailer was
the director if anybody wants to look
that one up in film history he was a
great studio mainstream studio director
and did some really good work but David
really liked it and he wanted to option
it and work on it with me and I said but
that sounds pretty good and I was what
20 23 24 I think I was 24 at the time
and that's what that's why I never went
back for the second year and Beyond and
I never did my dissertation for the for
the doctoral degree because I was bought
out of there and paid to write a
screenplay and I was 24 and maybe a
little more cocky than I should have
been I figured I got this knocked you
know I'm I'm I'm off and running and
well the first life lesson it was to be
another eight years before I got my next
assignment my second assignment but I
was doing PhD in theater so I had been
writing stage plays for a number
years but that's what it was it was
called the menopause of Henrietta luck
and it was I was a romantic comedy what
sparked the idea for the novella good
question where do these would become one
four year old oh I don't know um I don't
know I'm not sure I could tell you it
was it was a woman a rather reserved
woman in her late 30s was was the main
character the heroine and she had a
father who was crotchety and uppity and
mentally not quite all there and that
just kind of came I think from family
history we have a lot of eccentrics in
our family so you know I was working the
old your own family sort of material so
then what did your own family think of
you leaving this ph.d program right ed
UCLA to quote/unquote go to Hollywood I
mean you're still in LA but you're
crossing the line into town another part
of town and then become an adult and not
as a perpetual student there was fine
lisanna no I was I'm a very lucky person
when it comes to prayer to parents
really truly I mean we were what would
you call it middle class lower middle
class basically as a family but I had
two loving caring wonderful people for
Brett for parents and I learned to value
that more and more his life goes on
truly truly that was a blessing and my
dad was the scientist and my mom was not
an artist in and of herself but she's
the one who understood it you know go do
what you're good at so no no they
understood and the plan was always that
I would go back well one thing led to
another and
I never did go back to the ph.d program
so that you have their blessing you you
sell this script is that right if it
made no no it's not made okay
and what are you doing in that eight
years what's your progression of mood
output during that eight years
well after that basically up to that
point I had never even been in a room
with a motion picture camera in the same
room so my girlfriend at the time Diane
she had applied and gotten into the
American Film Institute and I said ah
sounds pretty good and that's better
than going out into the world and going
to work so I applied to and we both got
into American Film Institute and we both
already had a master fine arts terminal
degree in theater from UCLA and then we
went into the master Fine Arts program
at the AFI myself as a screenwriter and
Diana's a director she's a wonderful
director and so we got to hide out for
another three years but after that then
I focused on writing and so did you
think that it would just be a matter of
a few years until you churn out the next
script and sell it again and you could
sort of capture lightning in a bottle
again no I wasn't that optimistic
optimistic yes you have to be to a
certain extent but I'm also a realist I
just knew I had to do it and it was
another speaking of luck
Diane was another major major part of my
luck because this lady took a chance you
know the very very few what young
beautiful women I think would be willing
to take on a guy from nowhere who said
he was going to be a writer fat chance
right you know put all her marbles on
that and she did and I just
it was an amazing journey and that she
took that chance was some and I just
kept working and I started to get work
okay if you're a writer in any form in
any genre if you're a writer
you're going to get kicked in the teeth
I mean that's that goes with that goes
with the territory
it's just that's the way it happens so
you got to get used to certain things
you have to find that self met peace
within yourself and toughen your skin
get alligator hide because it's coming
and it is calm and then you just try
every the best way possible that you
know how to do to learn from it all
learn from it all and I was not an
advocate I was pretty shy kid basically
is what it comes down to I was not a
tremendously outgoing person at that
time I didn't hadn't mastered mastered
that skill yet but I felt I had a plan I
knew I couldn't do it by bashing on
bashing on doors kicking doors down
pounding on tables I give to exaggerate
to make a point I wasn't one of those
people but what I could do is make
myself inevitable by continuing to crank
out original material and that is
exactly what happened I just kept
writing and I just kept rewriting and
rewriting until they were pretty darn
good so when opportunities came as
eventually they did I was ready I had
scripts different genres you know what
do you want what do you want to see I am
ultimately I ended up with a top well I
am NOT going to bandy names about at
this point but a top agent literary
agent in Hollywood which kind of changed
everything and you know made other
things possible and it was just because
I had a drawer full of scripts but I
would I would like to say this before we
move on I've written 17 feature
screenplays
for remuneration you know on assignment
shall we say of those seventeen six got
made of those six I get screen credit on
five of the five I get shared screen
credit on three and sole screen credit
on two and the reason I like to run that
down for people is that is a pretty
typical career career arc for a working
screenwriter it's not what a lot of
people coming into the field think it's
going to be no basically you end up
making your living and it can be at
times a very good living office stuff
that is never going to get made because
whether it's made or not those are
financial decisions those are business
decisions and your original material you
crank out can be very very good and be a
good work sample but I have a number of
scripts that were never made never never
optioned yes but never made because they
were wrong in their timing for the
business of that at that moment so
that's truly I think kind of a glimpse
of the true nature of this business I
don't think it's changed too much since
then people need to know that who are
genuinely interested and fantasize or
see the possibility of them becoming
screenwriters they need to buckle down
for the long haul because that's what it
is
you